in the enemy of my enemy Professor
George Michael argues that anti-semitism
opposition to the Iraq war and anger of
our America's relationship with Israel
unites militant Islam and the extreme
right he spoke about it recently for
around 40 minutes and I'd like to thank
all of you for making it here today I'd
also like to thank the staff at Barnes &
Noble's for setting up this lecture my
name is George Michael I'm a professor
at the University Virginia's college at
wise and this afternoon I would like to
talk about my most recent book the enemy
of my enemy this book examines what I
see as an increase in convergent between
a convergence between two seemingly
disparate political movements that is to
say militant Islam and right-wing
extremism now of course both movements
have gained quite a bit of notoriety
over the past two decades or so and at
first blush there would seem to be
little common ground between these two
movements for example after all the
extreme right generally tends to be
derisive towards non-whites and would
not consider Muslims of the majority of
whom trace their ethnic ancestry to
third-world countries to be to be part
of their exclusively white community and
for their part the more radical Islamist
they look as scant sometimes at
non-muslims whom they sometimes
designate as infidels and to consider
them to be an existential threat to the
the Ummah that is to say the the
universal community of Muslims in the
world so suffice it to say there would
appear to be major ideological anthea
theological differences between the two
amendments but although seemingly
disparate the two moments actually share
some strikingly similar characteristics
in fact not too long ago our President
George Bush he even conflated fascism
with Islamism after a terror plot was
foiled in England back in August
President Bush said something to the
effect that we are at war with Islamic
fascist
so both movements share some qualities
for example they both endeavor
to create their own utopian visions of
homogeneous societies of course the
extreme right espouses racial separatism
militant Islam envisages a unified Ummah
under the leadership of the new caliph
and moreover increasingly there is a
meeting of the minds on several
important political issues including
oddly enough the Palestinian issue both
movements also share a similar critique
of American foreign policy in the Middle
East they also they are also both highly
critical of the American media now one
particularly dominant thread running
throughout both camps is a fervent
anti-semitism also both movements share
opposition to the war in Iraq and a US
presence in the Middle East so thus
under certain conditions there would
appear to be potential for greater
collaboration between the two movements
in the future so how did I get the idea
for this book well several years ago
when I was conducting research on my
first book I got on several email
discussion list of various extremist
groups and immediately after the attacks
of 9/11 I received emails and I visited
some of these web sites and I couldn't
help but infer a sense of schadenfreude
oh and these various extremist
discussion lists and postings of course
schadenfreude ax is a German word that
means that somebody derived satisfaction
or pleasure over someone else's
misfortune so immediately after 9/11
mainstream commentators were asking how
and why that such thing happened they
did not really seem to have a very clear
answer they said America was attacked
because of the values that our nation
espouses things like freedom democracy
and individual liberty
however the extreme right dismissed all
this is really being facile propaganda
representatives of the extreme right
believed that they knew the real answer
why America was attacked and they
maintained that America was attacked
because of its unstinting support for
the State of Israel so initially the
9/11 attacks seem to have seemed to have
had a catalyzing effect
on the American extreme right and the
extreme right in Europe for that matter
after all the issues about which the
movement feels very strongly loomed
large in the attack for example
immigration multiculturalism American
foreign policy in the Middle East
arguably all of these issues were
related to the events surrounding 9/11
so I thought it would be interesting to
not only examine the connection between
the extreme right and militant Islam but
also how both movements viewed 9/11 and
its consequences of course the extreme
right is one movement that is not really
encumbered by political correctness so I
think in that sense by examining its
analysis of 9/11 and related issues
perhaps that could kind of serve as a
canary in the mind that is to say it
might give us some idea where we might
be heading in the future but first
something before I go into let me define
some terms what do I mean when I say
extreme right some of the
characteristics of the contemporary
extreme right include often a
conspiratorial worldview often there
racialist they're very anti status that
is to say suspicious and critical of the
federal government and also
anti-semitism figures very prominently
in the contemporary extreme right as
well and these groups and individuals
that compose the extreme right are
really on the fringes examples would
include groups and individuals such as
the national lines various neo-nazi
groups and so-called Holocaust deniers
or Holocaust revisionists some of the
the less radical and more respectable
representatives would include persons
like David Duke and the remnants of the
Liberty Lobby which is now known as the
American Free Press their rhetoric tends
to be less strident but they are often
categorized as the extreme right
nevertheless
what is militant Islam sometimes this
term is used interchangeably with
Islamism basically Islamism is the
religion of Islam transformed into a
contemporary political ideology usually
with a more radical Ben Daniel Pipes
some of his critics call him an
islamaphobe but be that as it may he has
endeavoured to put together a definition
of militant Islam he wrote a book a few
years back called militant Islam reaches
America and according to pipes some of
the characteristics of militant Islam
include a radical utopian worldview of
totalitarianism often they are
anti-democratic anti moderate anti
Western and anti-semitic
now right-wing extremists and Islamic
radicals actually have made for strange
bedfellows for quite some time now and
the first real phase of cooperation
between the two movements really goes
back to the time of the Third Reich
Adolf Hitler he maintained a very
cordial relationship with the Grand
Mufti of Jerusalem
his name was Haj Amin al-husseini and
Hussein he spent several of the war
years in Berlin and while there he was
treated as a foreign dignitary and one
could say he even had like a friendship
relationship with Hitler but during the
war he helped organize a buffin SS
division and Yugoslavia and is called
the hon Chartres division and it was
composed of Bosnian Muslims and besides
that division there were other ver macht
or German army units that included
Muslims from the various Soviet
republics of course some of the Muslims
in the Soviet Union they resented the
repression of Islam under the Soviet
regime moreover many of them did not
really like living living under the the
yoke of the Soviet government and of
course Hitler's war against the British
and the French electrified many Arabs at
that time as well after all Germany was
fighting against the two principle
colonial powers that is England and
France and there are actually Arab
Bugzilla units that assisted Field
Marshal Ervin bramwell's Africa Corps
and indeed North African theatre during
the war so Germany's struggle in World
War two dovetailed with the
anti-colonialist aspirations of Arabs in
the Middle East and for Hitler he was
very proud of his stature among Muslims
and near war's end he even regretted
that he had not done more to really take
advantage of that particular Alliance so
after the war several former former
German military officers and Nazi Party
officials were granted sanctuary in some
Arab countries most notably Egypt and
Syria and so this really began the
second phase of cooperation some of the
more notable Nazi figures included Otto
Skorzeny Johan Phan layers and Otto
Raymer they were granted sanctuary in
Egypt and while there they helped
develop the military services
and intelligence agencies of these
countries Otto Skorzeny he was out of
Hitler's top commando and it was he who
led the mission to rescue Benito
Mussolini in 1943 and so skirts a knee
trained thousands of Egyptians in
guerrilla warfare moreover he even
organized early Palestinian terrorist
forays into Israel and Gaza and nd Gaza
Strip Gaza Strip in the mid-1950s johan
found liras he worked for the propaganda
ministry under dr. joseph goebbels and
after the war he helped churn out anti
Zionist propaganda so at that time
German national socialism or Nazism it
appealed to many of the early pan Arab
leaders including the the leader of
Egypt the leader of Egypt Colonel Gamal
Abdel Nasser it was really seen as an
effective way to build a strong state so
the next phase of cooperation commenced
in the early 1970s the rise of
Palestinian terrorism caused some
elements of the extreme right to once
again take interest in the Middle East
for example there were there was a small
German neo-nazi organization called the
the Hoffmann sports group and members of
that group sought to develop and
operational alliance with some Middle
Eastern terrorist groups and some of
their members even trained in some of
the Al Fatah camps in Lebanon another
example was a mr. Francois Jean Eudes he
was a leader of a Swiss far-right
organization and he also helped finance
several palestine palestinian rejection
groups such as the Alpha Tau
Organization the Popular Front for the
Liberation of Palestine and also Black
September and a Belgian Jean Francois
teary a he served as an advisor to the
pl o--'s Fatah organization he is also a
member of a neo-nazi organization called
the European nation and finally there
was a small neo-nazi group that was
better known by its initials the V SBD
and it carried out joint attacks with
Arabs on Israeli and Jewish targets and
Europe but despite the
and other incidents no enduring bonds
between the two movements were really
forged and the best the ties were really
sparse shallow and sporadic be that as
it may that these were followed by still
more efforts and in 1980s for example
the Libyan leader Colonel Muammar
Qaddafi he developed an ideology known
as the third position and it was
basically cast as an alternative to
communism and capitalism at that time
Qaddafi took a very strong anti Marik
anti-american and anti Zionist posture
so his defiance of the US government
attracted some elements of the extreme
right at that time during that period
anti Americanism was becoming more and
more salient in the in the international
extreme right so on occasion Qaddafi
would invite extremists to Libya from
both the extreme left and the extreme
right however having said all that
nothing really concrete came out of his
efforts but be that as it may there were
several developments underway that
really led to an increasing convergence
between the two movements
throughout the late 1970s and 1980s both
the extreme right and militant Islam
became more radical so there were
ideological developments in both
movements that thus contributed to a
convergence in their worldviews and as
each movement really escalated
there are denunciation of their enemy
they found more common ground
so what really intensified during the
1980s was the identification of Jews as
the primary enemy for both movements now
previously there were other entities
like the Communists the Council on
Foreign Relations the Trilateral
Commission etc that share of the animus
of the extreme right however by the
1980s Jews and Zionists were identified
really as the puppet masters of all the
extreme rights enemies both the both
Jews and the US government were seen as
the principal enemies with Jews pulling
the strings and of course this notion
was expressed in this acronym Zog or zo
G that stands for Zionist occupation
government and that acronym gained a lot
of currency in the discourse of the
extreme right also around that same time
in the late 1970s and 1980s the more
secular nationalist
resistance groups in the Middle East
were being eclipsed by the more radical
Islamist organizations first in 1979
there was the Iranian Revolution led by
the Ayatollah Khomeini he established
the theocracy in Iran and in doing so he
really strengthened the legitimacy and
appeal of militant Islam in the Middle
East increasingly pan-islamism rather
than the more secular pan-arabism was
seen as a more effective we more
effective means by which to effect
change in the Middle East and of course
that same year the Soviet invasion of
Afghanistan really sounded the the
clarion call for jihad throughout the
Islamic world and of course Afghanistan
would go on to be the incubator of the
major jihadist organizations that would
go on to the devil of the United States
and the years to come
and finally the Intifada
which commenced in the occupied
territories in Palestine in 1987 sort of
a similar process of Islamic ization of
the Palestinian resistance movement now
prior to that rebellion Palestinian
militants had generally been more
secular and left-wing in orientation
however after that rebellion the new
militants increasingly sought
inspiration from Islam and used it as an
organizing principle for resistance and
most notable in this regard was the
organization Hamas and the Charter of
Hamas actually contains elements of the
the anti-semitic and notorious protocols
of the learned Elders of Zion the
protocols of the learned Elders of Zion
of course is a staple and the the
literature of anti-semitism goes back
almost 100 years or so but anyway the
the end of the Cold War and the demise
of communism contributed to an
increasingly anti-semitic and
anti-government view of the extreme
right now during the Cold War communism
was still viewed as a threat however
once that threat was removed Jews and
Zionists really became the principal
enemy communism was seen as kind of a a
distraction for some of the movement so
today of the extreme right and militant
Islam share the same enemies they both
assert that the American government is
controlled by a kind of shadowy Jewish
elite cabal so this meeting of the minds
between the two movements has continued
so another phase of cooperation began
around the 1990s
one interesting example is mr. Ahmed
goober
Ahmed ubirr said on the board of a
financial firm called al taqwa sometimes
it's referred to as not a management but
not long after 9/11 the Bush
administration accused not a management
of being an important cog in Al Qaeda's
global financial network Huber is a
swish Swiss national and he converted to
Islam in the early 1960s and he styles
himself as being kind of an intermediary
between the extreme right and militant
Islam and Europe and over the past 40
years he claims to have developed ties
with major figures in the Middle East
and former of including the former Grand
Mufti Haj Amin al-husseini the Egyptian
President Gamal Abdul Nasser and the
late Ayatollah Khomeini of Iran when I
interviewed him he spoke of the
Ayatollah Khomeini in glowing terms he
told me how he sat on his side of his
feet when he gave a speech from a
balcony in Tehran Huber also claims to
be the first European Muslim to speak
before the Iranian parliament which he
did for the first time in 1983 besides
Huber still other right-wing extremists
have been attracted to the dynamism of
militant Islam for example David Myatt
David might he's considered to be
England's chief proponent of the
contemporary neo-nazi ideology he's also
the principal theoretician of revolution
but anyway several years ago he
converted to Islam and he even adopted
the nom de Geer Abdul Aziz and on his
website he openly announced the support
for Osama bin Laden so during the 1990s
both movements began to recognize some
ideological similarities what is more
9/11 really accelerated this convergence
of interest so after the twin towers
collapsed some representative
representatives of the extreme right
exalted they thought that it was kind of
a just punishment that the United States
deserved because of its policies in the
Middle East they also expressed
admiration for what they saw was the
valour of the display by
the hijackers have one could I think
even in Furyk a sense of envy on the
part of the extreme right some commented
that they wished others in their
movement really had that same kind of
fanaticism and dedication among their
followers yet despite these episodes of
cooperation and enduring terrorist
alliance as yet really to be established
and there are really several obstacles
that really militate against this
happening for one thing there is really
no extreme right terrorist
infrastructure in place rather
leaderless resistance that consists of
actions by individuals or very small
groups accounts for the vast majority of
acts of right-wing violence what is more
the extreme right is closely monitored
by law enforcement agencies and private
groups such as the anti-defamation
league and the Southern Poverty Law
Center and of course this would make
cooperation a very risky proposition for
both parties so thus even if Middle
Eastern terrorists were willing to
collaborate with American right
terrorists they would really be
hard-pressed to find a viable network
through which they could work however in
the area of propaganda there is greater
potential for collaboration between the
two and some far-right figures have even
soldier into the Middle East for example
a few years date a few years ago David
Duke he went to the country of Qatar and
he appeared on a television talk show
program that was broadcasted by the the
Al Jazeera Network more recently he
traveled to Syria he expressed
solidarity with the with the Syrian
people he was very critical of the Bush
administration and the so called
neoconservative conservatives and the
influence they exert over the Bush
administration so there does appear to
be increasing cooperation between the
two movements at least on a rhetorical
level now traditionally such efforts
tended to move in one direction that is
to say some members of the extreme right
would on occasion voice support for
Islamic radicals however Muslims were
usually much less reciprocal
however there is anecdotal evidence that
suggests that this situation could be
changing right-wing extremist propaganda
is being acquired and recycled by some
Islamic radicals and knows most notable
in this regard is so-called Holocaust
denial or Holocaust revisionism which is
found fertile ground in some parts of
the Islamic world some Islamic countries
have sponsored conferences in which
these Holocaust revisionists they
present papers and lectures in which
they impune the generally accepted
version of the Holocaust and earlier
this year I think it was in March the
country of Iran hosted one such
conference about a year ago
the current iranian President Mahmoud
Ahmadinejad he first publicly dismissed
the Holocaust as a myth and a few months
ago he really gave a very remarkable
interview to the prominent German
magazine Der Spiegel and in it he really
invoked several of the major tenants of
Holocaust revisionism for example he
said that the Holocaust was used as a
pretext for the creation of Israel in
the Middle East he also suggested that
it was being this tragedy was being used
as a form of moral blackmail and the
west so that Western governments would
support policies favorable to Israel
even voiced skepticism over the six
million figure of the number of Jews
that perished in the Holocaust he also
pointed out that some of the so-called
Holocaust revisionist historians have
faced criminal prosecution in Western
Europe and that seemed to that seem to
infer that he believed that there was
some kind of concerted effort to conceal
the truth surrounding the the Holocaust
and you may recall this this past spring
not long not long after the controversy
surrounding the publication by a Danish
newspaper of a cartoon which depicted
the the Prophet Muhammad as a terrorist
the government of Iran announced that it
would have a contest for the best
Holocaust cartoons and just a few weeks
ago an exhibit opened in Iran which
displayed cartoons the
barraging the Jewish Holocaust so this
is probably the area where there's most
potential for an alliance between
militant Islam and the extreme right
after Medina jawed started making these
remarks he was praised by extreme right
figures and organizations such as David
Duke the Institute for historical review
and the National Alliance moreover
representatives like the Muslim
Brotherhood and Hamas also praised
President Ahmadinejad as well
so what else accounts for dis
convergence well one factor that seems
to be drawing the extreme right and
militant Islam together is that
increasingly both see their struggles
and global terms both are searching for
an identity in an era of globalization
for example Osama bin Laden he
encourages Muslims around the world to
view their regional conflicts not as
these kind of isolated parochial battles
but rather as theatres of a larger war
in the defense of in the defense of
Islam against the West and Zionism now
likewise some elements of the extreme
right some elements of the extreme right
view their individualist their
individual national movements as part of
a a larger struggle for white racial
survival against a rising tide of
non-white demographic expansion which is
said to be orchestrated by the forces of
globalization and international Judaism
now in this regard the Internet is very
important because it really allows these
kind of disparate groups to spread their
message and exchange ideas two years ago
the the noted French scholar of Islam
Olivier Roy he wrote a very interesting
book it was called globalized Islam the
search for a new luma and it and in the
book he argued that Muslims in the West
particularly the young Muslim men they
often experience a trauma of what he
referred to as the territorial ization
because they felt estranged from their
native lands so to overcome the sense of
alienation young Muslims would look for
solace
a new purified form of Islam so they
attached themselves to what he referred
to as a a virtual Ummah or a Muslim
community built on the worldwide web now
in a similar fashion several years ago
two other researchers Jeffrey Kaplan and
Leonard Weinberg they observed in
another study the the rise of a euro
euro American radical right they
observed that scattered elements of the
extreme right in Europe and the United
States faced with certain trends such as
declining white birth rates massive
third world immigration and diminishing
life opportunities for working-class
youths have made them come to feel as
strangers in their own land
so by community communicating through
the medium of the internet they have
sought to developing a new pan Aryan
identity based on race and civilization
that transcends national borders now
it's worth mentioning to be sure anxiety
about immigration inhibits cooperation
between the two movements after all the
extreme right especially in Western
Europe fears demographic inundation by
Muslim immigrants yet despite their
concern with non-white immigrants
extremists on the right still see Jews
really as the principal enemy of the the
so-called Aryan peoples and although
militant Islam generally as choose
racial themes its version of
anti-semitism in many ways parallels the
anti-semitism of the extreme right for
example both the extreme right and
militant Islam charged that a Jewish
conspiracy is seeking to undermine their
societies through a kind of cultural
poisoning now according to an extreme
right narrative state an extreme right
narrative narrative would go something
like this the chief aim of the Jewish
conspiracy is to defile the white race
through miscegenation or racial mixing
thus ultimately that's supposed to lead
to the to its extinction as a distinct
racial group they maintain that you see
whites as their primary or most
dangerous rival so therefore if they're
kind of diluted through
such a nation than their most serious
rival would be removed now using a
similar narrative but in the framework
of religion militant Islamists argued
that Jews seek first and foremost to
destroy Islam because it constitutes the
strongest moral challenge to perceive
Jewish perfidy in this regard both
right-wing extremists and Islamist often
invoke the status of Palestinians as a
symbol of what awaits them if they do
not act swiftly it's worth mentioning
that right now there's currently an
ongoing debate in Western Europe over
within the extract extreme right over
who constitutes the principle on an
enemy some say that Muslims constitute
the most immediate threat others say no
the traditional enemy or Jews are still
the principal enemy so currently the
extreme right is really divided on this
idea of an alliance with Islam some or
for they see a possible synergy by
combined combining efforts with
like-minded Muslims others though think
that this is really preposterous they
think it's wrong headed they think it's
a bad idea they see it really is a
one-way ticket to public relations
oblivion
moreover they argue that it would give
the authorities all the more reason to
repress them now but be that as it may
they still believe that the ongoing
conflicts in the Middle East and the
plight of the Palestinians and the
occupied territories present an
opportunity to really deal Ajith amide
is rayul
both movements were also very critical
of the Bush administration's decision to
go to war against Iraq and the fact that
several of President Bush's
neoconservative visors were among the
most vocal advocates and favorable in
favor of the war also happen to be
Jewish was not lost on either group and
of course they cited this as proof
positive of being some kind of Zionist
conspiracy so what do all of these
trends presage well in the conclusion of
my book I predicted that if the
situation in Iraq would continue to
deteriorate then conceivably the extreme
rights critique of American foreign
policy in the Middle East might become
more mainstream and recently two very
prominent academics weighed in on this
issue of u.s. foreign policy in the
Middle East one was John Mearsheimer
he's a professor of political science at
the University of Chicago the other was
Stephen Walt he was the Dean of Harvard
University's John F Kennedy School of
Government arguably the most prestigious
school of political science in the
United States now I want to make very
clear I'm not suggesting that they are
part of the extreme right or anything
like that but together back I think in
March they released a working paper and
this paper was called the Israel lobby
and US foreign policy and in this report
in essence they argued that the various
interest groups lobbying on behalf of
Israel had subverted foreign policy in
the Middle East to the detriment of US
national interest and the report
occasion quite a bit of controversy for
example the esteemed civil liberties
attorney Alan Dershowitz he was quick to
point out the stylistic parallels
between that report and traditional
anti-semitic canards of Jewish due
loyalty and malfeasance and he even went
so far as to assert that the author's
cold information for the report from
so-called hate sites on the internet now
I think these allegations appear
spurious but nevertheless all the report
did contain certain themes
have formed the basis of classic
anti-semitic narratives for example it
argued that Jews used their influence in
the news media and in the political
system on behalf of Israel so not
surprisingly the report was very well
received by representatives of the
extreme right and Islam militant Islam
for example David Duke he expressed
satisfaction that his criticism of
Israel had been vindicated by such
esteem academics like wise
representatives of Hamas praised the
report as well and actually distribute
copies of it of it to their followers so
it's really difficult how acted to
predict how this convergence between the
two movements will unfold in the future
but the extreme right is worried that
certain trends things like large-scale
immigration and multiculturalism could
one day foreshadow a similar similar
situation what we have seen over the
past two decades or so that is that is
to say several countries have imploded
due to these kind of centrifugal ethnic
rivalries and there's this fear that
perhaps September 11th and its
consequences have the potential to
really amplify these trends and fears so
if the war on terror should falter
conceivably more people in the United
States and in Europe might become more
receptive to their views what is more
the intellectual legitimacy granted
through the Holocaust deniers within the
Muslim world could ultimately prove
significant as well so if you folks have
any questions I'd be glad to answer them
as best as I could if you could if you
have any questions if you could maybe
just move over here to my right
Oh with the Iranian president what
effect do you think the Holocaust
revisionism has had on yes I think it
appears to me based on the
pronouncements that Mahmoud Ahmadinejad
has made that the Holocaust revisionists
have had a significant influence on him
and I know over the past at least five
six seven years some of the Holocaust
deniers from the West have made their
way to Iran Iran even produced I think a
film about a year or two ago which
dramatized the the plight of the
revisionist hard historians was claimed
that they faced criminal prosecution in
the West and it was a sympathetic movie
depicting them as being kind of these
embattled dissidents and yeah they have
on occasion sponsored conferences as I
mentioned earlier Mahmoud Ahmadinejad
has invoked several of the tenants of
Holocaust revisionism and the most
recent interview he gave to their
Spiegel and Hince and in his various
pronouncements so moreover he seems to
be actually escalating his rhetoric so I
think they have had the significant
fluence on the Iranian president
yes sir
beyond anti-semitism what are the
agendas of the American extreme right I
can see what it is for Islam which is
sort of a caliphate that's been publicly
stated but yeah what does the American
extreme right want to get out of this
beyond this anti-semitic policy well
there's a centrality of anti-semitism in
the extreme right and I think that has
become more pronounced over the years
they basically see them as the primary
enemy ultimately they would like to have
an explosive white community there are
different plans they have for that other
others sometimes we call for an
expulsion of say all non-whites from the
country and of course some people would
say that's not really viable so some
advocate creating a rump state in the
northwest
sometimes that's referred to as the
northwest imperative where the United
States would in effect be dismembered
and there would be different enclaves
enclaves of different racial and ethnic
groups but they they charge the Jews
they're the primary enemy that they've
that they're the main instigators of
certain trends that are behind declining
birth rates and mass immigration and
things like that and so that's why I
think there's this kind of meeting of
the minds between the two they're
anti-zionism and anti-semitism of course
have different roots but in this
particular case I think there is an
increasing convergence between the two
if you read some of the pronouncements
of Osama bin Laden they they're
strikingly similar to some of the more
radical elements of the extreme right
like dr. William L Pierce he charges for
example that used this
disproportionately compose a number of
the more important positions in the CIA
and intelligence agencies and government
agencies and things like that and so the
parallels I think are really striking ok
yes sir with the oil plots in August and
London do you think that the extremism
Islamist will start using leaders
resistance like extreme right so a
certain degree they have leaderless
resistance means that rather when
working within the context of a formal
large terrorist organization that
basically individuals take their cues
and and work on their own initiative and
of course all that is really facilitated
by the new Internet technology Osama bin
Laden he can release his pronouncements
in fact Waze or his religious religious
edicts on al Jazeera and on the internet
and things like that and Muslims of
course have access to the World Wide Web
Muslims in the West and they can buy
into al-qaida's ideology without
actually being part of the formal
organization and that's really the
genius of Osama bin Laden although his
organization has been greatly dismantled
dismantled in the wake of 9/11 be that
as it may his ideology has survived and
so al Qaeda has really been transformed
from a formal terrorist organization to
more of a stated the mind organization
or an ideology so young Islamist yes are
increasingly do that doing just that if
you look at things like the the London
bombings in 2002 I 2005 and the most
recent terrorist plot that was foiled
these individuals did not really have
concrete alliances with the al Qaeda
organization in Afghanistan but they
were really able to work on their and
act on their own initiative
yes ma'am why is everybody so mad at
Jews
yeah that's it's hard to give really a
short answer for that I think both
movements will selectively take certain
things and then kind of put a mosaic
together and try to implicate Jews as
being the source of they're the primary
source of their prams so yeah I think
they're that's a big concern today if
you listen to the director of the the
national director of the anti-defamation
league mr. Abraham Foxman he talks about
the so called new anti-semitism that's
be deviling the world today and he talks
about some of the trends that really has
increased anti-semitism and one of which
is the the internet and I submit ik
diatribes can be can be transmitted on
the internet by way of email much more
quickly than in the past
and so I think that has really been one
of the things that has led to this
increase increasing salience of
anti-semitism in recent years
okay any more questions